do you think Israel has the right to
defend its borders I think Israel has a
responsibility to protect those that it
occupies I think you have to ask that
question differently um you
[Music]
know uh wrote uh a tremendous article on
this from a legal perspective you know
when you talk about Israel defending
itself
um Israel is bound to occupation law
this is the problem all along you know
when when when John KY said of course
the US is great sometimes at issuing
inconsequential statements that Israel
has to choose whether or not it wants to
be a Jewish or a Democratic State be a
Jewish or a Democratic state but it
can't be both um Israel wants to occupy
and deny and at the same time not be
held to the standards of being an
occupier but be treated as if it's some
normal uh State uh those borders were
drawn across occupied land and have been
expanding into Palestinian territory and
people have been thrown out of their hes
systematically and transgressed upon
even to the in the places that they fled
to which is Gaza right so when you talk
about Israel having a right to defend
itself you should be talking about
Israel's duty to protect everyone under
its occupation either lift the
occupation or protect everyone under
your occupation uh where are your
borders right what what is uh your
responsibility who are you protecting
and I think that it speaks to the fact
that Israeli policy considers
Palestinians to be animals they say as
much and they do as much I've spoken
about James Baldwin um and James Baldwin
talked about this Pious silence
surrounding Israel that we're supposed
to
pretend uh like it's just another state
uh you know and and ignore how it came
into being and what it functions as and
I think that Pious Silence has to be
broken you know I remember uh John
Stewart when he had the Daily Show
several years ago and he talked about
this uh policy of uh you know we have to
defend ourselves and if if someone was
attacking your home what would you do
and uh the response was well why are you
forcing people into a closet so you
force people into this desperate
situation you you drive them out of
their homes claim their homes and then
say that you're defending yourself
against them the default is that an
occupied people have a right to defend
themselves the occupier is obligated to
those that they
occupy can you speak to this term
occupation in
Gaza because the people that say it is
not an occupation say that Israeli
troops have been pulled out from there
before October 7th for many years yeah
and to you it still is a deao occupation
Israel doesn't get to set
the terms and then Define them uh it is
an occupation according to any uh legal
standard international legal standard
Israel controls the movement of everyone
in Gaza it controls the air and the Seas
uh it controls the ability to import or
export the people that live in Gaza and
the people that live in the West Bank
the
Palestinians have had their identity
stolen from them so there's the freedom
of movement there is the freedom of
thriving there is self-determination all
of that has been stolen from the people
of Gaza there's no airport in Gaza that
was destroyed by Israel as well uh it is
an occupation uh at at at every level
and by any meaningful legal
determination